the network's increasingly in in coming
years are going to be threatened by
people skipping their ads and therefore
reducing some of their a good part of
their revenue and and people not wanting
to watch things that network scheduler
says you have to wait till 10 o'clock on
Thursday night to watch this show
they're not gonna have the patience for
that anymore because they're being
taught by vehicles like platforms like
Netflix not to have to wait anymore so
what can the network's do that's
original they can do sports which is
very expensive and networks can afford
Reed Hastings and Netflix can't afford
that but a broadcast network can surf
and do sports they can do live special
events look at the Academy Awards big in
people around the world watch that
that's extraordinary and you get huge ad
rates for that they can do reality shows
you know they can do live events again
something that that some of these newer
platforms digital platforms can't do and
that increasingly is the view of many
people what will happen to networks the
networks will do fewer series and more
live events the question that is who
does the series series are pretty
expensive to do Netflix does you know
series but they're only 2% of their
budget is art our originals so where
will the money come from to do to
support the kind of expensive program
that is a question now in HBO which is
the most profitable of all these
on-demand networks HBO did 1.8 billion
dollars worth of profits last year
that's huge a lot more than Netflix
there and and unlike Netflix they own
all of their own shows you watch The
Sopranos you watch Game of Thrones
that's owned by by HBO so forever they
can repeat those shows and and it's they
they receive the money because they own
it Netflix doesn't even own house of
cards
they rent it so for a couple years
several years you'll be able to watch
house of cards on Netflix but then the
owners have asked the studio their owns
house
cards could decide to sell it to someone
else and so that's a vulnerability that
a company like Netflix has and a company
like HBO doesn't have one of the
advantages that Netflix has they have
some disadvantages and we've talked
about them they don't own their own
programming for instance and and and to
expand overseas it's very expensive and
so their their profit margins are very
small compared to say HBO's profit
margins on the other hand a writer comes
to them and they say to the writer or
director they said it will give you a
commitment will give you to your
commitment and we won't have to you
won't have to test it and by the way
instead of writing a show that's 40 or
42 minutes long which is what after you
subtract the commercials for an hour
drama that's what a network drama is
yours will be all our so dear writer
what writer wouldn't like to write a
longer series a series where he or she
doesn't have to constantly recap and
build up for the commercial break and
then build down and build up for another
commercial break but in fact can write
as if they're writing chapters of a book
that people could read consecutively so
I can build characters the writer says I
can actually create the complexity that
you see in a novel that you often don't
see in an hour drama